so in the last video i talked about
vector fields in the context of two
dimensions and here i'd like to do the
same but for three dimensions
so a three-dimensional vector field is
given by a function a certain
multi-variable function that has a
three-dimensional input given with
coordinates x y and z
and then a three dimensional vector
output that has expressions that are
somehow dependent on x y and z i'll just
put dots in here for now but we'll fill
this in with an example in just a moment
and the way that this works just like
with the two-dimensional vector field
you're going to choose a sample of
various points in three-dimensional
space and for each one of those points
you consider what the output of the
function is and that's going to be some
three-dimensional vector and you draw
that vector off of the point itself
so to start off let's take a very simple
example
one where
the vector that outputs is actually just
a constant
so in this case
i'll make that constant the vector 1
0 0.
so what this vector is it's just got a
unit length
in the x direction so this is the x-axis
so all of the vectors are going to end
up looking something like this where
it's a vector that has length 1 in the
x-direction and when we do this at every
possible point
well not every possible point but a
sample of a whole bunch of points
whoops
we get a vector field that looks like
this
at any given point in space you get one
of these little blue vectors and all of
them are the same they're just copies of
each other each pointing with
unit length in the x direction
so
as vector fields go this is relatively
boring but we can make it a little bit
more exciting if we make the input start
to depend somehow
on the actual input so what i'll do to
start i'll just make the input
y 0 0. so they're still just going to
point in the x direction but now it's
going to depend on the y value so let's
think for a second before i change
change the image what that's going to
mean the y-axis is this one here so now
the z-axis is pointing straight in our
face that's the y
so as y increases value to you know one
two three the length of these vectors
are going to increase it's going to be a
stronger vector in the x direction a
very strong vector in the x direction
and if y is negative these vectors are
going to point in the opposite direction
so let's see what that looks like
there we go so in this in this vector
field color and length are used to
indicate how the magnitude of the vector
so red vectors are very long blue
vectors are pretty short and at zero we
don't even see any because those are
vectors with zero length
and just like with two dimensional
vector fields when you draw them you lie
a little bit this one should have a
length of one right because when y is
equal to one this should have a unit
length but it's made really really small
and this one up here where y is you know
five or six should be a really long
vector but we're lying a little bit
because if we actually drew them to
scale it would really clutter up the
image
so a couple things to notice about this
one
since the output doesn't depend on x or
z
if you move in the x direction which is
back and forth here the vectors don't
change and if you move in the z
direction which is up and down the
vectors also don't change they only
change as you move in the y direction
okay so this is we're starting to get a
feel for how the output can depend on
the input
now let's do something a little bit
different
let's say that all three of the
components of the input
depend on x y and z but i'm just going
to make it kind of an identity function
at a given point x y z you output the
vector itself x y z so let's think about
what this would actually mean
and let's say you've got a given point
some point floating off in space
what is the output vector for that well
the point has a certain x component a
certain y component and a z component
and the vector
that corresponds to x y z is going to be
the one from the origin to that point
itself
let me just draw that here
from the origin to the point itself
and because of how we do vector fields
you move this so that instead of
stemming from the origin it actually
stems from the point
but what the main thing to take away
here is it's going to point directly
away from the origin and the farther
away the point is the longer this vector
will be
so with that
let's take a look at the vector field
itself
here we go
so again you kind of lie when you draw
these like the vectors these red guys
that are out at the end they should be
really long because this vector should
be as long as that point is away from
the origin but to give a
a cleaner vector field you scale things
down and notice the blue ones that are
close to the center here are actually
really really short guys
and all of these are pointing directly
away from the origin
and this is one of those vector fields
that is actually pretty a good a good
one to have a strong intuition of
because it comes up now and then
thinking about what the identity
function looks like as a vector field
itself
in the next video i'll talk through
another example that's a little bit more
complicated than this and can hopefully
give an even stronger feel for how the
output can depend on x y and z